the terror and the turmoil have been
replaced by something that looks like
normality we saw people on the streets
of Khartoum and a group of volunteers
cleaning up the pro-democracy protest
site last week the authorities crushed
that protest killing at least 118
activists calling for a civilian
government were beaten or shot and
driven from their camp in the middle of
the city they turned the technical
school in green into an art center and
library and the art remains as do the
soldiers this group are members of a
notorious unit formerly known as the
Jango weed and they wouldn't let us into
the complex yet the stench of what
smelled like dead bodies emanated from
inside
[Music]
for me because I a CPC
photo my web store all my office one
woman a psychologist works at a clinic
at the back of the school
why did the army come to your clinic you
don't know and she wanted us to see what
they have done she's a psychologist but
the soldiers are not going to let us go
to her office
experts at the United Nations fear this
country is sliding into a human-rights
abyss a sentiment shared by the staff at
the royal care hospital they've admitted
casualties from dozens of protests and
street occupations like I mean who was
beaten and shot in the arm is the
revolution over the protests over now on
the second floor we found a man called
Faisal alta here who was shot twice in
the back during the military crackdown
last week he found it difficult to
describe what he'd been through
his friends and relatives are angry for
they doubt the military will compromise
but they're also determined flashing the
protesters symbol of resistance as we
left the room John sparks Sky News
cartoon